a lot of people are going to be
traveling for this memorial day weekend
but not everybody a lot of people are
going to stay here in the valley
including bianca holman i believe he was
live on the las vegas strip this morning
with some family friendly activities
over at the grand canal shops good
morning bianca
hey good morning john good morning alex
yeah we've got so much to offer here in
vegas even coming here to the grand
canal shops
you should stay here if you live here
because we have so much to offer and
again we've been exploring the grand
canal shots from
the stores upstairs uh we got again
jimmy choo store wiseman we've got the
whole kitten caboodle
and then again all the family-friendly
activities the instagramable moments the
restaurants i mean the list goes on and
on janet
it really does and here we are right in
st mark square which is just an
incredible location
to enjoy patio dining at some of our
iconic restaurants
and of course enjoy the free live
entertainment on three different stages
including st mark square now tell us
more about this entertainment it like
you said it is free but
can you give us any a little bit more
details sure all weekend memorial day
weekend five days we have live bands on
three different stages
we have our iconic streetmaster which is
inspired renaissance
live vocalists and performers we have
our
vespa team here celebrating 75th
anniversary of vespa giving away
great treats and then of course we have
a great reward program this weekend
spend 200 and get a 25 dining voucher
to one of our restaurants so you really
can't go wrong for memorial day weekend
spending at grand canal shops
you can really spend the whole day here
like you said after you did some
shopping upstairs
grab something to eat enjoy the show the
free uh live entertainment that you have
here and also some instagramable moments
uh
we've been seeing of course absolutely
instagramable moments throughout the
property
and of course we have incredible
attractions both family friendly
like madame tussauds -5 ice bar
and great shows such as camus ultra
karaoke
and atomic saloon show which is really
just
an amazing show by spiegelworld and
we're so proud to have them at grand
canal shops
this is wonderful again vegas has so
much to offer so
again come down here to grand canal
shops i've tweeted out my wishing tree
video
make sure y'all go to twitter and check
it out i finally figured it out
uh but again so much to offer here and
we're gonna of course tweet out this
information for you guys to check out
can i send it back to you guys in the
studio and what are your plans john and
alex what do y'all got going on are you
coming here you want to go check out the
karaoke bar
are you going to sing i want to get on
one of those gondolas i i think i
yes the gondolas are so romantic i'm uh
scheduled to go to jimmy choos
he's going to buy you some shoes back
he's getting
thank you thank you angler sharing is
caring
thanks bianca yeah what have i got
myself into now it is it's on tv too so
we're gonna hold you to it now it's
official